- Demi, don't you think that's enough?
- No, it's never enough.
- Demi, Demi please.
Demi, please.
(upbeat music)
Hey everybody so we're here
at the Honda Civic Tour
Future Now where Demi
Lovato and Nick Jonas
are preparing for their
big tour across America.
Today I'm here because their fans
are about to make a bunch of
decisions for them on Twitter.
It's a Twitter adventure with
Demi Lovato and Nick Jonas.
Let's go, it's gonna be
great, it's gonna be great.
Nice to meet you, nice to meet
you, Demi nice to meet you.
Let's get down to it, you guys
are going to send out things
and all of your fans are
going to decide what you're
going to do for the rest of the day.
- I think leaving my daily choices
in the hands of my fans is a great idea.
- You look so nervous.
- Yeah I'm nervous, they're
going to decide what I do.
- You know you left Twitter for 24 hours.
- I did, so I owe it to my fans.
- Yeah, you should give them
the opportunity to control you.
- Twitter, I am your (beep).
- Let's have you tweet right now.
We're about to do a taste-test,
we're going to send out on your Twitter
which of the gross foods
you're going to choose.
Sardines, crickets, baby food.
- You know they're going to
pick the (beep) crickets.
- [Nick] I don't think the
crickets are actually (beep).
I think they're just, they're dead.
- What if I barf on you?
- Well then, that will be a
great rest of the day, you know.
Uh I'm a sympathetic vomitter
so I'll just pass it along.
- What?
- I think baby food's got it,
you guys are eating baby food.
- Okay, oh that's nasty.
- No, no, no, no that's Thanksgiving.
- [Demi] That's (beep) nasty.
- It's baby Thanksgiving.
- Which means what?
- It's gravy, turkey and stuffing I think.
Who wants Thanksgiving, who wants peas?
- [Demi] I'll have peas.
- I'd love Thanksgiving.
(laughing)
This is your fault.
Mmh it's great.
- Mine taste like peas.
- Yeah great, great for you.
This tastes like Thanksgiving apparently.
- I'm gonna I (beep) love you guys.
I'm in great thanks with them.
- [Nick] What was that?
- She's in great thanks with them.
- (beep) the both of you. (chuckling)
- Woah, woah, so you're
going to tweet out right now,
Demi needs here makeup done,
should I apply her makeup
or should she apply her eyeliner
with her non-dominant hand.
You're so nervous.
- [Demi] Yeah,
I don't want to walk around
botched eyeliner today.
- It won't be botched.
- [Nick] God forbid.
- What, you should have confidence in him.
- Oh I was talking about my liner.
- You're gonna do great.
- [Demi] Thanks.
- You need to have...
- [Both] Confidence.
- You know, my confidence
is getting there.
It's real close.
- Oh, that's one of my songs.
'Cause you probably follow
her on Twitter and not me.
- I do follow you, woah, woah.
Alright we're gonna follow him,
we're gonna get the makeup done.
- The levels of the emotions in here.
- This is too much.
- Don't poke me, just
got lasik, no big deal.
- [Nick] Just hold your face still please.
(laughing)
- Your hand is shaking.
- [Nick] Just adding an
extra element of intensity.
I was made for this.
It's not bad, it really is not bad.
- No it's really not bad.
That eye is almost flawless.
I'm so impressed, I'm
so impressed, thank you.
- [Nick] Anytime.
- [Keith] Well you look great now.
You guys have both sort of
faced off against each other
but we had a few requests from people
that they wanted you to prank somebody.
- Well Kelsey's not in here
and she's my assistant.
She's really fun to (beep) with.
- Great, well let's (beep) with her.
Internet wanted you to use a glitter bomb,
silly string, or an air horn.
So we're going to have you tweet that out.
Can we say "About to prank somebody"?
- [Keith] Yeah, for sure.
Great so the internet chose glitter bomb
but we decided we're just
going to do all of it.
Okay, everything's going great so far.
Nick's got the glitter,
Demi's got the air horn.
Well we missed her with
the glitter entirely
but otherwise that went great.
We're sorry.
- [Kelsey] What is that?
(air horn)
- You're terrible at pranking people.
I'm sorry that was bad,
your glitter was awful.
- [Nick] Subpar.
- No it was so bad.
- It was bad, so we need to find out
which one of you two is
ultimately the best person.
- (chuckling) The best person.
- Either ping-pong, great equalizer.
Or motorized scooter
race, but it's going to be
up to both of your fans to figure it out.
- [Nick] Okay.
- Alright let's do this.
- Alright so why don't you
put it out on your Twitter
but you retweet it.
That's it.
So we're gonna let that time pass.
So your Twitter followers
said scooter race.
So there's your scooters,
we're gonna have you
race from here all the way
back to your dressing room.
On your mark, get set, go.
- [Demi] You started early (beep).
- [Nick] Oh sorry.
- [Keith] Nick starts out as a (beep)
- [Demi] Bye (beep).
- [Keith] Taking the lead, she's done it.
- [Demi] I win.
- [Keith] Demi you did it.
You crushed it.
- [Demi] Thanks.
You crushed him like a tiny bug,
like a tiny little
grasshopper you got crushed.
- I'm a better person.
- So now you get to ask
your Twitter followers,
what to do to me because I
made you do all this nonsense.
She just sent out to all her
fans the punishment for me
which will either be a bucket
of ice water, pies in the
face, or she's going to
give me an atomic wedgie.
Which a lot of people love
to have an atomic wedgie...
From you.
- [Demi] Oh cool.
I don't think that's a thing
you would want to give.
- No.
- [Keith] But it's true.
- Thanks.
- You're still just as
nervous as when we started.
- Because I don't know
if I'm going to have to
reach in your pants
and give you a big one.
(laughing)
- Me neither Demi.
Well that's it guys, you did it.
And your friends chose unfortunately
to dump a bucket of ice water over me.
So that's what we're going to do.
- Any last words?
- Just three huge celebrities hanging out,
playing on Twitter.
(chuckling)
You know what I'm saying?
I'm deeply attractive.
(chuckling)
- That was so fucked up.
- Don't laugh louder when
you're called out on it.